all right let's check out the last air
bender which is pretty nostalgic it was
actually one of my favorite shows as a
kid I think it was on Nickelodeon I
didn't even know it was anime and I
wasn't a Christian at the time so I
wasn't worried about any of the magic or
the elements or the Witchcraft in it so
uh I'm pretty curious to watch this
trailer having a different perspective
so to speak I resonated with Ang being
the only vegetarian in his friend group
and I remember him really sticking to
his principles um but even though I
really enjoyed the show as I began
taking my Christianity more seriously I
realized that I had to stop watching it
all right we're going to watch Avatar
The Last Airbender new Netflix movie
Here We
Go the fire nation is embarked on a dark
part Fire Nation and the world might
never recover oh wait is it another
movie about the end of the world always
okay so right off the bat I think it's
interesting it's always about this like
Armageddon end of the world stuff it's
like every single time yeah and there it
is there's that like Perpetual Hollywood
storyline no originality to movies
anymore the Earth is going to be
destroyed and it's usually by someone
coming from the sky it's the end of the
world and whoever's coming we need to
fight against that person in the case of
Avatar it's actually the Fire Nation and
if this doesn't ring alarm bells to a
Bible believing
Christian maybe don't watch this film
and go read Revelations it's interesting
that they're talking about the fire
kingdom is coming to like really do some
damage to the world and it's not going
to recover from that um I mean
spiritually speaking that's what
Christianity is really teaching that
there's an end to this crazy mess that
we have down here on this planet and
it's going to end in fire so I I find
that an interesting um piece that
they're putting in
there the world needs the Avatar
oh who needs you
[Music]
Ang the Fire Nation has destroyed
everything in their
path oh the Fire Nation okay so the fire
Nation are the bad guys and they've
destroyed everything in their path so
already I'm thinking if it's the end of
the world and it's being destroyed by
fire and the bad guy is the one who's
destroying with fire I'm just I think I
think Gnostic because I've seen it so
many times in movies but I'm thinking
that they're going to make Christ the
bad guy the one that's coming to destroy
the world with fire let's keep watching
if the world is going to have any chance
it's going to need aim
right there goes the savior of the world
oh there we go whoa okay there goes the
savior of the world and he's like flying
around on a cloud there goes the savior
of the world if you compare Ang's
character with Christ is it going to
have more in Christ with or more in
common with Christ or more in common
with Satan in the storyline in the Bible
God doesn't take pleasure and
exterminate
but in movies time and time again you
find this figure who does the same kind
of Act of wanting to destroy the Earth
and they're so full of hatred or or
they're just a complete psychopath in
the movie is like the savior of the
world the one who is rallying everyone
together to fight against the person
who's coming to destroy the world
they're like this lovable relatable
person and everyone is on their side in
the Bible the one who is fighting
against the Earth's destruction that's
actually the devil and it's not he's not
doing it to save Humanity he has his
like own Twisted Vendetta something that
we really wouldn't want to be a part of
if if we knew the truth you know when
you read Revelation it talks about when
Christ returns that Satan is going to
unite all the kingdoms of the earth
together to battle against the coming of
Christ and so if if there's ever a
scenario where the world is going to be
destroyed by fire such as with the Bible
says and the and all of humanity needs
to come together to fight to save the
Earth then whose side are you on
according to scripture according to
prophecy you're on Satan's side as
Believers we are not fighting to prevent
the Earth from being cleansed of all
unrighteousness and all sin being wiped
off the Earth We're actually longing for
that
day I've chased down every hint of the
Avatar it's my
[Music]
destiny I'm not someone who can stop the
Fire
Nation I don't want the responsibility H
you don't have to do this well you have
me Tara and a flying ball is the savior
flying on a beast maybe is he dressed in
Scarlet riding a beast I don't know it
might be reaching there I just going by
what I see here good morning
the world needs
you remember what it is we're really
fighting
for the ones
we love it's the same it's the same
story it's it's Guardians of the Galaxy
3 it's everything it's always about the
one who's coming to destroy destroy the
Earth is is going to destroy the ones
you love so we have to fight together
it's always a UFO or Thanos or asteroid
or it's always some threat from the
heavens coming to Earth to destroy the
Earth with fire and going to destroy the
ones you love and we got to fight they
are always coming at this family
orientated um idea that we need to band
together and that we're fighting for
this thing called
love if you if you kind of just analyze
what is Christianity getting at it's
it's a we're fighting against sin and
selfishness and you know do we want to
um adhere to God's commands or not do we
want to do whatever we want and and and
see they they rope you in with you need
to be with the family but then it has
nothing to do with your morality it's
just like family and love I don't think
that just because we're doing it for the
sake of love is always a good
thing I'm the Avatar and I'm going to
save the
world with my
friends okay so what I want to know is
how is he going to save the world with
his friends um it looks like he's using
sorcery to me when you read Revelation
it says that all nations were deceived
by sorcery that um the Beast is going to
bring down fire from heaven and all
these things it's it's a nation deceived
by sorcery thinking that they can fight
God when he's coming to cleanse the
Earth and this is It's just amazing the
propaganda that comes out Satan is
trying to literally deceive the world
through media over and over and over the
same repetitious message Mass hypnosis
on all of
humanity
oh you definitely see all the element
Elemental witchcraft being used the I
just saw the Earth come up the water
swirling around the fire and he's the
air bender so of of course you have
earth air fire water which are the four
elements of Witchcraft representing the
pentagram the fifth point being Spirit
the Avatar here is sort of The Fifth
Element the spirit element and and he's
able to control all of these these
elements and in witchcraft you invoke
the spirits of the elements to come into
your Sacred Space and become one with
you this happens in Frozen you know air
fire water and Earth yes but look
there's a fifth spirit said to be a
bridge between us and the magic of
nature a fifth spirit and Elemental and
just uh Captain Planet you see it all
the time in mainstream media you're
always seeing earth wind fire water so
listen out for those key words when
you're watching entertainment this is
blatant sorcery now
the Avatar State wow that's the Savior
his eyes are glowing like that looks
pretty evil and demonic there's
something interesting that um happens a
lot in in movies that talk about
possession the eyes go completely white
there's some little Wayne videos where
he's rapping and his eyes are completely
white um you see it in different pieces
of media where they where they show you
somebody that's completely possessed
happens a lot in anime their eyes go
completely white so it's kind of
interesting that they they did that to
the Avatar and also the Avatar when you
look it up in the dictionary it actually
has ties back to Hinduism and it means
The Descent of a deity down to earth
decent of a God so an avatar really is
someone that thinks he's a God and he
was cast down to this earth well who's
that that's straight Satan he was
someone that called himself a of God
wanted to be worshiped as God and and he
was the one that was cast down to earth
so this is sort of once again Sympathy
for the Devil and using his means of
controlling the outcome of this war yeah
I remember a achieving the Avatar State
through it was like meditation or when
he was at this heightened state of
emotion you know what's tough about this
is there's a there's it's cultural
there's a lot of culture cultural
elements and I have appreciation and a
respect for differences in culture and
learning about them I know that the
Avatar series is based on a lot of Hindu
ideas taism ideas Buddhist ideas and so
you're kind of taking all of these like
worldly spiritual disciplines and
wrapping them all up into this uh
ability to manipulate the elements of
the earth that's actually straight up
witchcraft 101 the Bible tells us
completely to stay away from sorcery
magic divination um anything that is
considered magical abilities the Bible
never says that we should engage in this
kind of activity so um planting these
seeds into kids Minds is not a good idea
what I had to understand is Christ comes
first like above tradition above culture
above my desires or Nostalgia or
something that looks cool or is
attractive when we come out of the
world's tradition and we enter into
Christ's culture that means putting away
anything literally anything that comes
in conflict with righteousness Christ's
righteousness and in this case Christ
needs to come before spiritualism he
needs to become before yoga
meditation Elemental worship nature
worship Christ comes first and it's a
decision that each Christian needs to
make and and take seriously because
every decision matters might be some
people that say you know oh I don't
really buy into those ideas and you know
I'm not going to all of a sudden start
doing Buddhist things or whatever and
I'm just learning about these different
cultures and what they believe in I
truly honestly believe that you cannot
mix um truth and error together and
movies are powerful they're going to
plant seeds into your mind and so um all
of this imagery and and the use of magic
and sorcery I think we're coming into a
a end of the world scenario where we
actually are going to probably see very
Supernatural things happened I me the
Bible describes even fire being called
down from heaven um in the sight of men
and that alone is not enough for us to
believe in it that it came from God it
we have to actually take the Bible as a
whole and understand how God worked with
humanity and our faith needs to be built
on the word of God not necessarily what
we see and so when you kind of engage in
this type of media all the time you're
conditioning your mind to see these
Supernatural things and yeah if somebody
showed up right now and was throwing
Fire and Ice at everybody um I bet you
it's going to make you take a second
look you know and and and I think that
this is setting the world up in the end
for believing what their eyes are seeing
rather than what their faith is should
be built on is a thus sayith the word of
God I mean you might think just
nitpicking but you see this over and
over and over and if you watch more
videos on the channel you'll see over
and over and over we you you see the
same similarities the same aspect so uh
nobody writes a script for a movie
for just because like oh yeah um um yeah
the enemy is going to have fire and then
there's going to be this kid and little
boy and he's going to be the savior of
humanity yeah I'm just I'm I'm just
going to you know just come up with that
no you you write it in there on
purpose yeah and there are all the
elements listed at the end you know the
second commandment in Exodus chapter 20
says don't worship nature even goes to
specify we shouldn't worship things on
earth or things under the Earth in the
water we should focus on worshiping God
the Creator not the
creation then we have James 4:1 17 like
if we know what is right and we choose
not to do it that's sin and so I know I
wouldn't engage in Elemental worship but
if I'm watching people and and getting
pleasure and watching people doing
something that I myself wouldn't do it's
as if I'm doing that thing I'm
participating in what God identifies as
Sin so I I've learned
that a Christian who continuously
watches things that are explicitly
against biblical truth like it'll
eventually lead them to not believing in
the Bible anymore or what the Bible has
to say or they'll just start
experiencing some serious cognitive
dissonance and the reason why is because
by beholding we become changed but yeah
last air bender if you want to watch a
movie that propagates fighting against
uh the some tyrannical villain that's
going to destroy the Earth with fire and
we must unite the world together to
fight against him using sorcery and
Witchcraft then you're really watching
satanic propaganda that's preparing you
to fight against Christ's return so it's
a nogo for
[Music]
me